are you in the first years of your
career and often sitting in meetings
but you're often not really sure how can
i contribute
how can i join the conversation how can
i really add value
this is a feeling that many young
professionals have
and in this video i'm going to share a
couple of tips and tricks
based on my experience having worked in
consulting at mckinsey for about six
years
on what you can do to succeed in
meetings
as a junior consultant or as a junior
guy
in corporate or in any other role
similar to that so welcome to another
coffee break here on my channel firm
learning my name is heinrich and on my
channel i want to help you to become
successful
in the first years of your career so
we're gonna share three
super tangible and actionable tips and
tricks of what you can do to succeed in
such a meeting as a junior
and for every tip i will share a little
very personal story based on what
happened to me
in my professional life to really
illustrate these points and then based
on these little stories i will always
extract the learning which i trust will
help you
because for sure these were learnings
which were really valuable and
insightful to me but before we jump into
it i want to introduce you to the
sponsor of today's video
and this sponsor is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people
you can explore new skills deepen your
passions and get lost in creativity
there are classes on marketing
personal branding presentation skills
and many more all of these are topics
that are highly applicable to a career
in consulting
banking or corporate and the best thing
is that i made a slight writing class
for skillshare so you can access and
enjoy it as a skillshare member
personally i recently took the class
productivity masterclass
principles and tools to boost your
productivity from the fellow youtuber
ali abdal it's a great class it taught
me many new aspects of productivity and
i very much enjoyed how you applied the
pareto principle or the 80 20 rule to
productivity
classes on skillshare are specifically
curated for learning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay
focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you and the best thing
is that it's
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual subscription
skillshare created a special offer for
subscribers of this channel from
learning and so the first
thousand subscribers of me click on the
skillshare
link in the video description we get a
free trial of the skillshare premium
membership i hope this helps you to
explore your creativity
check it out link in the video
description so let's start with the
first tip and indeed let me share a
story
this is from an instance that really
happened during my consulting
professional life
i was on a project and we were having a
workshop with a client
i was the responsible associate who was
supposed to cover this workshop so i sat
together with a client who was
organizing it from the client
side i discussed it with him a little
bit i helped him draft some of the
materials for the workshop but then it
looked all good the workshop was
prepared and then it was happening on
the workshop day the client was the
leading the workshop
and i was pretty much just sitting there
i was still a young associate he was
presenting everything and i tried to
make a couple of remarks and comments
which i felt like were probably smart
and were adding value but the truth also
is that in this long workshop i didn't
really add much to the conversation
and this is then indeed also a point of
feedback that i got from the project
lead after the workshop
and she was telling me well heinrich you
were a bit too passive
you were not active enough as an
associate it should have been your role
to shape the whole workshop a bit more
so what i realized from this episode is
that what i didn't do what i should have
done
is to clarify my role before the meeting
this is indeed the first tip that i want
to share with you make sure that you
clarify your role
and this is true both for external
meetings but also for internal meetings
so often you're sitting was in these
internal meetings
there are some partners some senior
partners the project lead and then you
are sitting there
as a young associate as a young
consultant and then often you are lost i
mean what are you supposed to add to the
conversation right and indeed then
especially when also clients are present
then it's often the task of the project
leader maybe even the partner
to moderate the discussion and often in
these situations you
are as the junior guy also not the
deepest subject
matter expert at the topic that is being
discussed so on the content level you
will also
often struggle to really participate and
to add value
especially in these situations where all
these other senior guys are present
so my advice is that before these
meetings are taking place
talk to the responsible person so this
might be your client counterpart or
maybe your project lead if now you're
walking into an internal meeting with
all your partners
and really ask them how can you at value
what should your role be
and maybe make some suggestions what you
believe you could do and just some
examples so what could you do so for
instance if you present a larger
document maybe you agree on a certain
section in the document
that you will present that you will lead
maybe there will be a certain flip chart
session
during the workshop and then you can
leave this little session collect all
the questions
steal the whole discussion maybe you
will be the one who writes all the notes
and then in the end writes the meeting
minutes so all of these are little
things that can increase your
participation
your activeness will also increase your
visibility and if you are regular
watcher of my channel you know how
important in my opinion visibility is
for your career success and i especially
made one video about this topic of
visibility i will link it somewhere
above here it is also one of my older
videos but i believe the messages in
there
are still very very valid now for tip
number two let me share an additional
story and this is something that
happened to me when i was a project lead
and probably a similar things also
happened to me
with reversed roads when i was a more
junior guy on the team but at that
instance i was a project lead i was
sitting in a meeting with one of my
associates and he also was a more junior
associate he was only with the firm for
a couple of months we were sitting in a
meeting which was part of his module
right so pretty much the meeting was in
the end his responsibility in the sense
that he was responsible to cover the
topics that were discussed so then
during the meeting i has appropriately
tried to moderate the whole discussion
to steer the conversation in the right
direction but then there were occasional
moments where people were asking us
about data
about fights that they sent us what
certain numbers were how this all added
up
and my associate was just sitting there
pretty quiet pretty shy
didn't really say anything so then i
ended up opening my laptop pulling out
some files and pretty much sharing some
pieces of information that i wanted to
share back with the client and of course
to some extent here my expectation would
have been
that this is something that the
associate would do that as the module
owner he would have all these files at
hand
would be able to share all these numbers
in the meeting and this now leads me to
tip number two
and this is that especially as the
junior guy in the room
be the numbers guy so especially if this
is a meeting that is about one of the
topics that you are covering
in these instances it actually will even
be expected that of course you know all
your data much better and much more in
detail than the project lead also needs
to manage other parts of the project in
parallel to this specific part
of course you will have all your files
at hand of course you will know the most
important numbers concerning this work
probably even in your head you will not
even need a file for that right so of
course if questions are asked about
these topics
this is your moment this is your role
where you can jump in
and then share all this information that
you have at hand so being the numbers
guy is a straightforward and actually
pretty easy little thing that you can do
as the junior guy to add some value by
providing the relevant data
and i'd say even if it's a question
which is not directly belonging to your
area of responsibility don't let your
project lead or your partner in a
corporate context your boss or whatever
look this stuff up if you have it then
take this as your role you are the one
who can quickly look this up
ideally already come into the meeting
with maybe your laptop opened with the
most important files or spreadsheets
which will likely be the focus of the
discussion already open so that if such
a question comes up you do not need to
first
look for this file where you have saved
it open it and so on but you directly
have it in front of you can directly
tell them the numbers
these are these little great moments
where you can shine where you can add
value and these are things that will be
perceived by your team and also by the
clients so tip number three and now
again a little story from the perception
of a project lead so often you will join
meetings that your associates
schedule that are with clients that are
covered by your associates
just because the topic is a bit
sensitive or maybe the client is quite a
personality then maybe the associate
asked you to also jump in to sit in
there to try to help him to steer the
meeting into the right direction so one
thing that i observed occasionally was
that now i was sitting in these meetings
i was trying to help and i thought it
was a great meeting and then the meeting
was over all the clients left and i was
sitting there with the associate and
then i asked him or her
hey what do you think how did the
meeting go and then the associate says
well yes it went well but we didn't ask
the question we didn't got this piece of
information that we really needed and
then this often confused me and then i
asked the person well okay but
if you know that this was important if
you know that we needed to ask this
question as well then why didn't you ask
and this was something that i
occasionally observed with more junior
consultants that as soon as somebody
more senior than them
sits in the meeting sits in the room
sometimes they feel like okay now the
meeting isn't my responsibility anymore
or maybe they are too shy and believe
that well if this would be
really important then probably my
project lead or my partner would think
of that but of course often it's the
other way around right often the partner
is the furthest away from what is
actually going on in the project then
the project lead will as well
be already much further away than you as
an associate so take this as your
responsibility as well and this is my
third tip
so make sure that all the key results
that all the next steps
are really clear and defined and if you
feel like for whatever reason something
important is just not
raised by the more senior people in the
room but you know that it is important
then raise it then ask that question
then address it
do not believe that this is not your
role to ask this or that you're too
intimidated to address this point that
you know is so important
of course be aware of politics maybe
it's a very sensitive thing maybe there
was a reason that the project lead or
whoever was sitting in there with you
didn't raise it so of course try to be
sensitive for these types of things as
well but in general i believe that it
really
rarely hurts if you as the junior guy
really push for tangible results and
next steps that i agreed in the meeting
so hope that you find these three tips
helpful so first clarify your role
second be the number guy and third push
for clear next steps and results
if you do this i trust you will add lots
of value to the meeting and this will
give you a very clear sense of what you
actually can do
if you sit in these conversations so as
always if you have any questions about
all of this please leave me a comment
below in the comment section as you know
i will answer every single comment that
you write and of course every comment
that you write also helps me with the
youtube systems if you took any value
out of this video at all please hit the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on all my content
if you want to see more from me also
follow me on my instagram my handle is
firm learning you can also reach out to
me on linkedin or sign up for my mailing
list both of these links you can find
below in the video description if you
want to start learning and claim that
free trial use the link below in the
video description to sign up and i want
to end by also saying
thank you to all the members of firm
learning you're really making a
significant contribution to my work on
this channel so if you're thinking about
becoming a member as well and also
profit from member only perks hit the
join button next to the subscribe button
to learn what this is all about if you
watched until here thank you for
watching until the end
i'm releasing new videos every single
saturday so looking forward to next week
next saturday to the next video
until then goodbye this is heine from
from learning
cheers guys